we've already talked about the notion of
a monopsony employer in other videos but
now we're going to review it a little
bit and we're gonna introduce a twist
and the twist is what happens when they
have to deal with a minimum wage and it
will see it's kind of counterintuitive
so first of all just as a review a
monopsony is a situation where you have
one buyer and you have many sellers of
something and when we're talking about a
monopsony employer the buyer is the
buyer of Labor we're talking about the
buyer in the labor factor markets and
the seller are the workers the people
who would sell their labor for a wage
and we have already studied monopsony
employers situations before but I will
redo it it never hurts to get the
practice in the vertical axis you have
the wage which is really the price of
this factor of labor that we're studying
right now and in the horizontal axis you
have the quantity of the factor that we
care about and this is quantity of
labour now we have seen this show many
times before you're going to have or you
typically have a downward sloping
marginal revenue product curve and that
describes a situation where every
incremental unit of labor you bring on
the marginal revenue the incremental
revenue you get goes lower and lower and
lower because of arguably diminishing
returns in some way so this is marginal
revenue product of labor you can also
have marginal revenue product of capital
or of land other factors and then we can
think about the supply of labor well
actually
really what we're trying to get at is
what is the marginal factor cost curve
and if this employer were not a monopoly
employer if they were just operating in
a perfectly competitive labor market the
marginal factor cost curve would just be
the market wage so it might look
something like that but we are dealing
with a monopsony employer and so they
don't just take the market wage they
have you could view it as a supply curve
for a laborer that's specific to them
because remember they're the only show
and down they are the big employer and
maybe in this small town and so you have
this supply curve this this is
ply of labour but this is not the
marginal factor cost curve and we've
explained this before but that's because
as you bring on higher and higher
quantities of labour you need to pay
more to that incremental person but what
typically happens is if you need to pay
one person more you need to pay everyone
the same wage so as you bring on that
incremental laborer not only have to pay
more for that incremental unit but you
have to raise the wage for everyone so
the marginal factor cost goes up twice
as fast as the supply of labour curve so
the marginal factor cost curve would
look might look something might look
something like this and then what's
rational is a firm would keep bringing
on that factors in this case labour
would keep hiring folks as long as the
incremental revenue that it gets from
hiring that in that next unit is higher
than the Inc than the marginal or the
incremental cost and so they will keep
bringing people on as long as the MRP is
higher than the MFC and so we would get
to that point right there and so it'd be
rational for this firm to hire this
quantity of labour let's call that Q sub
one and then what wage are they paying
pause this video and think about that
because this is always a little bit
tricky well you might be tempted to draw
a line here but remember this doesn't
describe the actual wage the wage of
that quantity is described by the supply
of labour so this would be the wage that
the firm would pay so now let's
introduce our twist let's think about
what happens if a minimum wage is
employed in this region that for
whatever reason the City Council says
hey that employer needs to be paying
more money and let's say they Institute
a minimum wage at I will do this in a
bold color let's say they Institute a
minimum wage right over here let's call
this wage sub M pause the video and
think about what would then happen what
would the marginal factor cost curve
look like and then what would be the
rational quantity for the firm to hire
all right so now that the the town has
instituted a minimum wage and it's
higher than the rational wage that
the firm would have otherwise paid for
labor what it does is it at least at a
certain range of quantities it of
quantities of labor being employed it
essentially makes this monopsony
employer have to think a little bit like
an employer in a competitive labor
market where you just have to accept a
wage now this wage isn't being set by
some market it's being set by a
government so as long as this wage is
higher than the supply of labor well
then this is going to be or higher than
our old supply curve well this is going
to be from the firm's point of view the
new supply curve so it's going to look
something something like this but then
when the supply curve when the wage is
that the supply curve describes go
higher than that minimum wage well then
it will track that so this is our new
supply curve right over here so new new
supply curve and we're talking about
supply of Labor and it's this whole red
thing and what would be our new marginal
factor cost curve well we said that it
has twice the slope but when the slope
is just flat here I'm going to do this
in a new color so the marginal factor
cost curve it's going to track this
horizontal line right over here and then
all of a sudden when the supply curve
starts to go up well then it's going to
jump back to the old marginal factor
cost curve so it's going to look
something like this so M F C I'll call
it 2 that's in blue so it tracks the
supply curve here when it's horizontal
and it is really just analogous to when
we just have to accept a wage and then
it jumps we have a bit of a
discontinuity and then you get up there
but what's rational as always is a firm
to keep hiring as long as the marginal
revenue product is higher than the
marginal factor cost so it's going to
keep hiring it's it's as long as this
yellow line is above the blue line it
would keep higher and keep hiring all
the way until this point right over here
so notice what just happened
it is now rational to for the firm to
hire more people and that is counter and
to ative and everyday thought if I
thought I was running some type of a
business if I was running a burger joint
and all of a sudden if there was a
higher minimum wage than it feels like
hey I might not have enough money to
hire people I might lower the number of
people I hired but we just showed at
least with some with a very simplified
economics model that theoretically when
you're dealing with a monopsony employer
it actually might get them to hire more
people so an interesting question is why
did this counterintuitive thing happen
and one hand-wavy argument but I
encourage you to ponder it is to realize
that in the old world
every time they brought on an
incremental person they had to raise the
salary of everyone and that's what made
the marginal factor cost go up so
quickly but now since you have this
whole flat part of your supply curve
because regardless of how many people
you hire in this range right over here
you're paying the same amount that
incremental person does not increase the
wage for everyone else so that is what
made it rational for the firm to go and
keep hiring now the community the
government the City Council would have
to be very careful about what this
minimum wage is because it's very
possible that they could overshoot and
actually end up in a situation where the
firm hires less so for example if they
made this the minimum wage right over
here let's call that w2 or w3 well now
all of a sudden you would have a
marginal factor cost curve that is going
like this for at least a good bit we can
think about it a little bit later as
what happens as you go further and
further to the right but then it would
only be rational for the firm to hire
that much and so then you would have a
decrease in employment but if we go back
to the original situation another thing
that you might be thinking about hey
this seems too good to be true it's now
rational for the firm to hire more folks
and those folks are getting more income
surely someone must be losing and it is
the case that the firm is now going to
lose more of I guess you could say the
surplus that it was having in the old
world and more of that is now being
given to the workers